do you think that men's cheating isn't
as bad as women's cheating because if a
woman cheats she's looking for a new
relationship or a man he's just trying
to it's both like torn it was a
tournamental again it damages both like
their other partners it's all about
self-control one in three men under 30
are either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year it's a very small
percentage so I'll give you an example
on dating apps women only swipe right
five percent of the time where men swipe
right fifty percent of the time so women
are much pickier than men
so it's a small percentage of men that
are cheating that's right like why do
you think women hate men because we're
the same ones